Uh oh, thank you very much for for
having me. It's I'm I'm very excited to
present here and thank you for for
inviting me, Yongu and and Tony. Um as
thanks for also for the introduction. uh
as uh as Tony mentioned before as as of
a couple of months ago I'm I'm at at
Stanford but before that um I was
working on my PhD and and on my post at
at ETA Zurich and in this talk I wanted
to to bring you an overview of of that
work um that that came out of of that
time and this in general concerns model
reduction applied to fluid dynamics
mostly and from the point of view of
invariant manifolds and so that means
it's it's mostly going to joint work
with George Holler in fact all of it and
also with other collaborators who will
be acknowledged as as I go along.
So I'm going to discuss um fluid flows.
So that means I'm I'm going to look at
solutions of the Navia Stokes equations
which which I have here. And as a bit of
foreshadowing here I I have two systems
that will be mentioned on the left. It's
a turbulent pipe flow and here this is a
fluid structure interaction problem
and some dynamical systems insight turns
out to be quite helpful for for these
kinds of systems. It was proposed a
while back that we should uh look at
solutions of this equation as evolving
in an infinite dimensional phase space.
So this would be the function space of
velocity fields
and u that means a fully time resolved
solution or or simulation or experiment
would be really nothing else just a
trajectory of this dynamical system that
I written sort of in a symbolic way as u
dot equals n of u and of course in in in
practical applications this is is never
actually infinite dimensional but but uh
but very high dimensional because of the
spatial discretization that we always
have to do. So it could be 100 thousand
or million degrees of freedom.
And this phase space is actually filled
with special solutions.
In the dynamical systems language, these
would be fixed points, periodic orbits,
quasi periodic um orbits and and so on.
And in this line of of literature, they
are called exact coherent states or
exact coherent solutions, ECS's for
short.
And it's a even though a trajectory
could be very complicated, it would be
sort of uh described by the the the
motion between these the pinballing
motion between these exact coherent
states.
And so this this will be very important
for later. And as a as an overview, I'm
I'm going to discuss to be more a bit
more specific, I'm going to discuss
dynamical systems in this form. So x dot
equals ax plus some nonlinearities where
x comes from a finite dimensional but
but possibly very high dimensional
vector space.
And u if there's one point I I want to
make today is that the one of the the
most important difficulties that comes
with with a reduced description of these
types of systems is the fundamentally
nonlinear or or nonlinearizable behavior
that can arise. And one hallmark of that
would be when when I I know that there
are multiple steady states that coexist
in the phase space. So they are
competing with each other. We have
multi-stability
or we have this this very complex
chaotic or turbulent behavior. If if
these are are true then then I know that
I have to somehow turn to nonlinear
methods for reduced order modeling. And
I could do that from from two points of
view. I could use the equations
uh or I could use data directly. uh but
using the equations is is quite
difficult usually just by the the nature
it's could be very by their nature it's
they are very highdimensional they might
be PTE
uh but more importantly um I might not
even know them in in uh in practical
applications or I might not trust them
enough and so so therefore we we usually
turn to datadriven reduced order models
and if I want to do this reduced order
modeling in a in a mathematically
justified and and defendable way. Then
one such setting where I I know that
that is for sure doable is when I know
that there is a lowdimensional
attracting invariant manifold in the
phase space uh of this dynamical system.
So if you look at this sketch um you can
imagine that there's this blue
trajectory sort of coming down attracted
to this um this flying carpet this this
green surface and it synchronizes with
its internal dynamics. So therefore if I
restrict my attention or restrict the
dynamics uh to to this invariant
manifold M then that would give me still
a good overall description of the
system. So this would be a good model
and this model is is going to be u
simple because the manifold is low
dimensional
um it's it's also attracting I assumed
it's attracting and that's very good
because I I have a chance of actually
observing this in simulations or or
experiments.
It is also manifold. So that means the
model is going to be smooth and um that
is very good if I want to do calculus on
it for example. But um even more
important is that it's it's also going
to be smooth in the properties of the
system. So I I know that it's going to
be robust against perturbations of the
system. And so that is is a that is very
important for a model because I I
ultimately want to to learn new things
um things I didn't know about the system
based on the model. And there therefore
because of the smoothness I can I can
sort of extrapolate knowledge that I
already have.
And finally what invariance buys us is
that this is going to be a closed model.
So as long as I'm on the manifold I know
that I'm for sure not going to leave it.
So there is no risk of of me running out
of the domain of validity of this model.
And one caveat that comes with this is
that for for this to be a robust
construction, structurally stable
construction, uh the manifold also needs
to be normally hyperbolic. What this
means is that the the the normal rates
of of attraction must dominate the the
tangential rates of attraction that that
happen inside the manifold. So um that
means the dynamics outside the manifold
must be much much faster than than
inside the manifold. So people call
these slow manifolds usually.
And uh what happens if this is not the
case? Well, here's an example of a of an
attracting manifold
invariant manifold. This uh this uh red
one that is not normally hyperbolic. You
can see that the the normal rates are
much weaker than the tangential rates.
And so what that causes is that a
general trajectory it's not even uh
acknowledging the existence of the
manifold. It's just sort of flying by
and it's only attracted to it right at
the very end when it's it's converging
to this fixed point. So I would say that
this is not a very good model of the
system probably.
But if uh if we look at a normal
hyperbolic invariant manifold like this
green one here
uh you see that the the normal rates
actually dominate the tangential rates.
So what that results in is that
trajectories are are compressed and they
are pushed together towards this
manifold and then they they converge um
synchronized with the internal dynamics
of the manifold towards the fixed point.
So this would be a very good model.
And uh now if if the existence and
uniqueness properties of of these
manifolds are cleared up and that's a
big if by the way but if they are then I
can I can now attempt to to parameterize
them to construct them. And then what I
would do is is pick a smaller set of
reduced coordinates such that I can
model their time evolution separately uh
with something called the reduced
dynamics. in in most cases in in our
applications these will be
lowdimensional ordinary differential
equations.
Um and I know that as long as I'm on the
manifold the dynamics is is consistent
with what's happening on in the phase
space. So that means um on this manifold
I can always return to the full face
with this so-called parameterization
map.
So I'm not losing any information.
And uh and one more thing to point out
is that this is a is a very popular idea
nowadays especially with with machine
learning methods and and artificial
intelligence based methods. People talk
about the manifold hypothesis. So that
data generally tends to live in in uh
live on lower dimensional uh subsets of
the ambient space. And in in fluid
dynamics especially this goes back to
the um to uh to the 80s with with
discussions on the inertial manifold
which is an invarian manifold that
contains all of the global attractors of
the system. Um and unfortunately in full
generality it's hasn't been proved for
the Navia Stokes equations that they
would exist but it's still a very nice
um sort of line of thought to to keep in
mind.
And what what I want to introduce now is
a special class of of invariant
manifolds that as as you will see they
they automatically put us in this in
this very nice slow manifold or or
normally invariant normally hyperbolic
invariant manifold setting. And uh I
just want to introduce or motivate that
very shortly.
Um so imagine this uh the system that I'
I've written down before but now let's
neglect the nonlinearity. So imagine
that this is a linear system x dot= ax
and I have a a fixed point in the middle
somewhere. I'm assuming that this is
hyperbolic but this could be stable or
or of settle type. So it can have both
stable and unstable directions. That
doesn't matter.
But in this case I I know that reduced
order modeling is very easy in fact
because ident spaces of this linear
operator are all invariant and by
superposition even their their
collections which we call spectral
subspaces
are are also invariant. So therefore, if
I want to reduce description, I could
just project onto the slowest one of
these spectral subspaces and that would
give me a very good model that is exact
in some sense.
Um and uh and everything else is just
just attracted to this this low spectral
subspace.
And the good news is that under fairly
generic assumptions on the on the linear
part of this dynamics, this can be shown
that this picture is essentially the
same in the nonlinear system. So that
there is a a similar slow to fast
hierarchy of invariant objects which now
they are invariant manifolds and they
are tangent to the the underlying
spectral subspaces of the linearized
system. They're also anchored uh just
like the spectral subspaces are they're
anchored to the to the the steady state
that I assumed is there. In general,
this would be a um a generic exact
coherent state.
And and not only are they tangent to the
spectral subspaces, but they can be
viewed as as a nonlinear continuations
of these spectral subspaces or nonlinear
extensions of the spectral subspaces.
But now they can carry nonlinear
dynamics. So they can support multiple
fix points uh limit cycles and and even
more complicated uh attractors as as we
will see later.
And and again, the most important one is
the is the slowest one of these spectral
sub manifolds, the slow SSM. Um yeah, we
call them spectral sub manifolds because
they grow out of the spectral subspaces,
SSMs for short. And we're usually going
to cons to concentrate on the slowest
one of them uh because that acts as an
attractor because every everything else
outside this uh this SSM is pushed
towards the SSSM. Um and uh and this
gives me a good reviewer model.
So um to start with I I want to to show
you an equation-driven example and this
is very simple. This is something you
can you can do with pen and paper. I I
took this example from uh from the book
of Guggenheimimer and Holmes. I I
modified it slightly but I I think this
will uh uh will be helpful to to go
through once. So u here we have x and y
coordinates and a fixed point at the
middle so at at zero and also this is
already in diagonal form for the linear
part. So I can immediately read off the
the slow spectral subspace which is the
x-axis
that is an invariant subspace for the
linearization
and by by what I I told you earlier it
it follows that then there is an SSM a
slowsm that is tangent to the to the
x-axis.
So then if I want to find it um then I
could assume that um that this function
re relationship holds. So the the other
coordinate the y-coordinate is
subordinate to the x coordinate with
this um h function
and um and I could now enforce the
invariance. So what that means is I time
differentiate this relationship and then
use the governing equations and that
gives me the the so-called invariance
equation. So I just uh differentiate
both sides. Substitute here x dot and y
dot where needed and I have the
following uh expression. Now this is not
not very good. This is still a nonlinear
equation uh for for h and in higher
dimensions this would be even more
complicated. This would be a partial
differential equation. So it doesn't
look like uh like much progress. But
what what saves me is that I I know that
these SSMs or or this SSM I'm looking
for is actually anchored um or or fixed
to this fixed point. So it goes through
the fixed point and I also know that it
is analytic. There is this is also
something that the theory gives you. So
I can look for it in the form of a
tailor series. And when I I do that here
I'm just showing the the leading order
contribution. This is a quadratic u
manifold that I get uh to leading order.
You can see that on in the face as well.
And then I can also um derive the
reduced dynamics
and uh this type of approach already
gives gets you very far. So people have
been constructing these invariant
manifolds in extremely high dimensional
systems especially my my colleagues um
they have been dealing with the
incredible um mechanical systems
um and u and and this approach scales
very well. uh however there is one
limitation which I want to show you
briefly
um and and to do that I I introduced
this uh this fluid dynamical problem now
so this is two-dimensional colograph
flow so this is the the vorticity
equation written on a on a
two-dimensional domain which is which is
periodic so it's it's kind of like a
Taurus and I'm forcing this with the
wave number of four
and for for low values of the rails
number it is known that that only this
solution um is is stable. So this is
this this banded um structure but it's a
certain reos number it becomes unstable
and another solution another stable
solution appears which is this this wavy
wavy pattern
and I know that there exists a
one-dimensional connection between them.
So this this um this one-dimensional
manifold going from the unstable fixed
point to the stable fixed point and this
this connection happens to lie along the
the one-dimensional slow SSM of the
stable fixed point.
So then it would be really nice if I
could uh for example just just knowing
the stable state I could expand um in a
tailaylor series this this one
dimensional slow SSM and then it would
ideally also go through this this
unstable fixed point. So that way I
could I could learn something new. I
could I could infer the existence of an
unstable point just based on information
uh on the on the stable point.
And this can be done for example just to
order three here is an approximation for
the slow SSM. Um it is quite good
locally but well um farther out it it
deviates.
uh the order five approximation is is
slightly better but still it doesn't
quite go through the uh the fix point
and uh here is the the issue that is
that is going to pop up. So if I I go to
very high orders, you see here an order
16 approximation
which locally it's extremely good uh and
I know that this Taylor series is even
even convergent on some domain. So this
gets better and better but at at some
finite distance it just turns around and
does something crazy. So um in this in
this case what happened is
this uh the boundary of the domain of
convergence was was much closer to the
stable fixed point than I hoped. It's
this uh this convergent expansion just
doesn't cover the unstable fixed point.
But uh I want to emphasize that there is
nothing nothing wrong with the
underlying SSM. This is just a defect in
the tailaylor series. And I I hope to
say something more about this towards
the end. It's a there is a way to get
around this but but generally this is
limitation that that pushes towards
datadriven methods because by the uh by
the attractive properties of these low
SSMs from data you will always see them
and so therefore you can use the data
itself to approximate it and and drive
your model
and um we have developed a pair of of
software packages in Matlab and Python
that allows you to do that in an
automated fashion. These are called SSML
learn.
And um I would now like to briefly go
through how it how it works mainly
because it it helps me fix the jargon or
helps me repeat some of the jargon.
So so we start start with here uh start
start here. Um assume that we know that
there's a d-dimensional SSM near an
exact coordinate state. So this is
something that that has to be given. But
remember that because SSM grow out of
the spectral subspaces to infer this
dimensionality, I just need to do linear
analysis. So that's not not very hard.
But the the main difficulty that that I
I run into now is that the phase space
in which this manifold lives is usually
not accessible. So it's not always
realistic to measure all of the degrees
of freedom of a of a system at the same
time. But luckily there are are theorems
embedding theorems that tell you that
you can embed um this this manifold in a
different space as long as you have
enough observables that you measure
along these trajectories. Um in
particular as long as you have um
observations more than twice the number
of observation observations is more than
twice the dimension of the SSM then you
can smoothly embed this this manifold.
So in this observable space imagine that
you have these uh trajectories coming in
and they converge along this SSM to the
fixed point.
So now I I organize them in a in a data
matrix and the first task is to is to
approximate the the coordinate chart. So
how do I get reduced coordinates uh from
this manifold and here we just use a
very simple assumption that this
manifold is a is a graph over its uh
over its spectral subspace. So in fact
this projection to the spectral subspace
will be the coordinate chart and and
here then I'm I'm uh I'm constructing
the basis or this tangent space it's
enough to to do a a rough approximation
just maybe using a singular value de
composition
and then projecting with them with those
b with with those basis vectors uh it
gives me a set of reduced coordinates
which I I label ada. So then the only
question is how do I go back? So how do
I go back from uh the reduced space to
the manifold? Um and that is the the
parameterization map.
And for the parameterization map we
assume that this can also be written as
a polomial function. This is just a uh a
functional approximation um uh task. At
this point we could assume also also
other um classical um functional
approximation methods but but we usually
use polinomials. Not always but usually.
uh and then what this problem just just
means is I I have to determine the
coefficients of these polomials and that
is a simple linear regression uh
problem. Now so very classical nothing
nothing too fancy with the numeric
but once I have the geometry now I can
uh I can go go after the reduced
dynamics. So I ask how these reduced
coordinates, these ADA coordinates
evolve among themselves.
And as I said, this will typically be a
lowdimensional order differential
equation um for the for the reduced
model. This is the model itself um that
we derive at the end.
And again the I I typically assume a
polomial form for this. So so
determining these coefficients is again
just a linear regression problem. I
would approximate the observed time
derivatives from from finite differences
or or something similar and then just
regress the the right hand side of this
polomial that gives me the the model.
Okay, so that roughly covers what I
wanted to say about the method and the
and the the theory let's say. So what I
I want to go to now is a sort of a
picture book of applications or or um a
collection of examples that we've
applied this methodology to.
And to to start I want to show you this
the so-called inverted flag problem
which is um is a is a fluid structure
interaction problem and it's it's in
fact a very nice case study I think in
in model or system identification.
So the the flag the inverted flag is is
really nothing else. this this elastic
sheet that is is clamped at at one end
and it is subjected to some um some
inflow from from the other unclamped uh
end.
And then um it well there is this the
rest state or the the fixed point of it
is is when the flag is not moving that
as soon as some flow hits the the flag
it becomes unstable
and some some more complicated dynamics
arises and um so we had Shu who was a
PhD student in our group and Joan
Liberty who was a master student they
worked together with Philip Kleti and in
in Philippo's lab they they built this
this experiment you can see a video of
it here the flow is the it's it's in a
water tunnel. So the flow is is coming
from below and it's hitting the flag and
and you can see that this gives rise to
some some interesting dynamics. Um in
this case the the most prominent feature
you you notice is is the the periodic
flapping
um which um some people argue that this
could be used for energy harvesting as
well.
uh but now for our purposes what we want
to do is is is model this dynamics and
um to an important component to to what
I said earlier is that we need to
somehow anchor this this invariant
manifold we have to anchor it to
something and this problem gives us this
anchor point very conveniently so I I
said that the the rest state when the
the flag is not moving it becomes
unstable but it is a fixed point
nonetheless of the dynamics so I can I
can construct its lowest spectral subman
manifold slowest SSM uh and uh in this
case it's going to be so-called a
so-called mixed mode SSM because it has
uh repelling and attracting directions
because it's an unstable fixed point but
this is a two-dimensional SSM in this
case and we can construct it by by just
tracking the the end point of this flag
so we we take a measurements of this
endpoint as a time series and use then
the embedding theorems to construct this
SSM
and the reduced dynamics on it is going
to be our our reduced model. So I'm I'm
showing you the the face portrait of
this reduced dynamics. This is a
two-dimensional dynamical system. Now
that we've uh we've inferred from data
uh you see in the middle there's the
undelected fixed point. So this is our
anchor point. This is a settle type. You
can see that some trajectories are
leaving, some are are approaching it.
And this this other nice feature is the
is this outer loop uh in blue which
corresponds to the periodic flapping
motion of the flag and that is
represented as a stable limit cycle in
this model. So now that that I I have
this this model I could for example use
it to make predictions on on new
experiments or or experiments that
weren't used in the in the training of
of this uh of this model. And you can
see that that we are doing a pretty nice
job of of capturing this transition from
low amplitude oscillations to in this
case it jumps qu pretty quickly to to
high amplitude oscillations and the the
stable periodic flapping sets in.
But I think what is more interesting is
that if if we look at the phase portrait
uh we see that there are two other fixed
points to the left of the undelected
state and to the right of the undelected
state. These would be deflected fixed
points. So when the the flag sort of
buckles to the left or buckles to the
right
and this is not something we've enforced
in the model this is something that that
uh it uh it came out from the analysis
and physically of course it means it it
makes sense that they are there. So if
you think about the mechanics of this
problem, it should be um
yeah, you should uh agree that there
there are these these two deflected fix
points in a symmetric way. But still
this is a a very quantitative prediction
that the model told us and so then we
can test it and that is exactly what
Genway did. So he he went back and tried
his best to initialize this flag uh near
one of these deflected fix points. You
can see that the deflected fix points
have a have local unstable spiral type
dynamics
as the model um would would say. So then
we can see what what happens if I
actually run this experiment.
Um so just as a model would predict we
we have smaller uh oscillations in the
in the beginning and they they start to
grow until eventually everything is is
collected by the by the limit cycle. So
in this case this is a quantitative and
qualitative umly
successful system identification I I
would say.
Okay. So the the next problem I want to
show you is is turbulent pipe flow.
And uh I think uh one of the reasons
that this pip flow is so interesting is
because of the way it transitions to
turbulence. It shows the so-called
subcritical route which means that this
uh this laminer profile that is is drawn
on the on the diagram never actually
becomes unstable even for infinite re
numbers but you do see turbulence pop up
at some point. So it means that this is
an inherently bstable system. So
sometimes you see the turbulent state,
sometimes you see the laminar state
uh and it depends on the initial
condition that that you give in the flow
or that that you let the flow evolve
from uh which attractor which which
state you end up in. And this you can
also see in the time series of the of
the energy input rate. You can either
very quickly laminarize or you can um go
to uh to high amplitudes and and do
these chaotic or turbulent oscillations.
And what I I want to do um with this
reduced order modeling task is to is to
capture this by stability. So eventually
at the end of the day I just want to
differentiate between turbulent and and
non-turbulent initial conditions in some
some way.
And if we we want to draw this the the
phase space of this dynamical system in
a in a very sketched way and this
bstability means that there has to be
some somewhere a boundary between these
two attractors. This uh this would be a
co-dimension one invariant manifold that
separates this phase space in this case
that is called the edge of chaos and on
one side you have this turbulent
attractor uh on the other side you have
the laminer base state
um and um and also an important feature
is that there are also um stable states
or not stable but but relatively stable
states embedded in the edge of chaos.
They are called edge states and of
course they are globally unstable but
they have just one um unstable direction
that points away from the edge. So so
this is what would take you to the
turbulent state and on the other side
laminer state.
And in this system I'm looking at here
this is a short pipe at at a low re
number. This is really just a traveling
wave solution an unstable traveling wave
solution. This edge stain
and um
Now the the strategy is to construct the
the slow SSM that is attached to this uh
this edge state. So in this case it's
going to be two dimensional to have two
um two directions. One unstable so it
will contain for sure the the unstable
manifold of this edge state but it will
also contain the slowest direction
inside the edge.
So you can you can sort of imagine it
like this that we're we're cutting
across with the slow SSM uh along the
edge of chaos it it will for sure
intersect transversely
um and um and therefore if I reduce the
system to this this low SSM in the
reduced order model I will have to have
some footprint or some imprint of the
edge of chaos uh inside this uh this
reduced model. So that will allow me to
differentiate between turbulent and and
non-turbulent initial conditions. And I
I just want to note that for for now I I
ignore the turbulent states. So once
they get far enough I I don't want to um
bother with that too much.
I'm I'm fine with just differentiating
between um the two types of initial
conditions.
So now we we again use data but but this
is a DNS now. So this is not an
experiment unfortunately. that we use
this DNS solver open pipe flow to to
initialize um trajectories that are are
close to the this this edge state but
they are are on on both sides of the of
this edge of chaos so they can either go
to turbulence or they can go to the
laminary flow and using that data I now
fit this this SSM this two-dimensional
slows
in this uh in this diagram or this
visualization I'm I'm using uh the
energy dissipation rate D and energy
input rate I as reduced coordinates. So
they are they are in fact physical um
coordinates and the Z direction is just
just the kinetic energy for
visualization. But here I'm I'm uh
actually reconstructing all of the
degrees of freedom of the system. So I
could pick any other uh degree of
freedom.
And then in this space uh you see this
this SSM this low SSM is this uh green
surface
and the edge of chaos would be cutting
across it somehow uh in where I I uh I
drew this uh this blue surface. Now
unfortunately the the edge of chaos is
very high dimensional
to be to be honest I have no idea how it
looks like. I wouldn't know how to draw
this. So this is just a just a cartoon.
But what is not a cartoon that is is for
sure um exists here is this uh this
orange line. So that is where the the
edge of chaos and my slows intersect. So
that is already a prediction from this
reduced model
and is probably best understood if I if
I look at the the face diagram or a
phase portrait uh of this of this
dynamical system. So again this is a
two-dimensional vector field.
Here is our anchor point. This is the
the edge state and here down here is the
laminer state. Turbulence would be
somewhere up here. But I don't care
about that. I I cut uh everything that
that leaves the box.
And um this intersection point this this
footprint of the edge of chaos uh is
really nothing else just a stable
manifold of this settleype fixed point
that I have here. And in this this two
dimensional vector field it's actually
super easy to find. So I can just
integrate backwards uh along the stable
vector and that would trace out this
this curve
and uh this is something again that we
can test. So what we've done is is
prepare a grid of initial conditions um
that are are intersecting this this edge
footprint. So they they are near this
this edge state but they live in the
full face base of the Navia Stokes and
then I I simply let them evolve under
the DNS. on the for model and what we
see is that this this grid is is cut
very nicely in half uh precisely where
our our prediction for this this edge
intersection would be. So anything above
transitions to turbulence, anything
below laminarizes quickly. So what this
tells me is that uh this one-dimensional
object is is is a real structure that
has real dynamical significance for the
for the dynamics of the uh of the Navia
Stokes.
But of course you could say that this is
just a glorified binary classifier,
right? Because I'm just differentiating
between these two uh types of behaviors.
And that is true except that uh here the
binary classification is is done by the
geometry of these invariant manifolds.
I'm just trying to find a a clever way
or or well not even clever just a way to
to get to this geometry to to use that.
Uh but still it would be nice to to to
model some some more complex behavior as
well.
And and to do that we actually have to
turn to a different flow which is which
is simpler in the uh in in some sense
but but still similar to pipe flow and
this is going to be plain quad flow. So
this is um a flow between two
um two planes two walls that are are
moving in the opposite direction. So
they induce a shear and this flow is is
also subcritical. So it's transitions to
turbulence in a subcritical way because
this constant shear solution this linear
profile is again always stable no matter
how large the re number is.
uh but we can see complexity appear here
um at a at a much lower reenos number
than u than than previously um that than
we've worked with previously. So if we
follow this bifurcation diagram
constructed very nicely by by Kridos and
Echart
um we see that at a a reos number even
below 200 there's an extended chaotic
attractor that is born um as a sequence
of bifurcations
and the other side of this chaotic
attractor the this uh there's also a an
edge state or an edge of chaos
that mediates the transitions between
the the laminer attractor and the
chaotic attractor. vector
that is this lower branch um fixed point
solution or computed first by Nagata.
Um but I I would like to emphasize that
this is not yet turbulence. This will be
a a chaotic flow. So this is not uh this
is temporally complex but not yet
spatial temporally. So this would be a a
baby baby step towards turbulence.
But essentially what what we we wanted
to see is can we apply the same
methodology. So right we have a an edge
state we have this unstable fixed point
here we have a turbulent or a chaotic
attractor on one side we have a laminar
attractor on on the other side and and
what if we constructed the the slowest
SSM of the system the slowest SSM
anchored to the the edge state can that
capture chaos potentially
and uh the the spectrum of the or the
linear dynamics near the edge state now
is is of settle spiral type. So there is
a a one-dimensional unstable direction
and a stable direction, a stable spiral
which is now two-dimensional. So that
means altogether my manifold is going to
be three-dimensional.
Um so so going from from two to three
now but if I if I construct that with
given some some simulation data also
from a from a DNS solver
then I can derive a model that that does
very well on on short-term uh short-term
predictions even in the chaotic state.
Of course, in the chaotic state, we know
that long-term predictions are
impossible because of the sensitive
dependence on initial conditions, but it
can nicely differentiate between lean
rising and and chaotic trajectories and
also it captures the long-term long-term
statistics of the chaotic attractor. So,
this is the the parallel spectral
density computed on the chaotic
attractor. You can see that we're doing
a uh an okay job.
And here's a a visualization of of what
happens in the in the reduced phase
space. So here on the left, this is the
attractor in the reduced space. Uh and
here this is what would would happen in
the real space. So when I I use the
parameterization to go back to the to
the the face space and translate that to
the the physical space, the channel. So
when I I let this simulation evolve, see
you see that we very quickly jump to the
attractor and then complete these twists
and turns in in whatever way uh along
it. You can see that we have this
chaotic wiggling of the of the vortices
of the of the quet flow.
Um
yeah, and maybe I I'm
uh a bit behind on time, so I I thought
I would uh I would would skip ahead. I I
skipped one example and skip to my my
last example, which unfortunately this
is this is not a fluid dynamical
problem, but a a solid mechanical
problem. I I hope you will forgive this,
but I was very excited about these these
results, so I couldn't resist keeping
them in the presentation.
And this will be a a beam model. So a
finite element model of a of a beam that
is is clamped on on both ends. Uh and
here we're going to use the equations.
So this will be um a very similar
example to the to the colograph flow I
showed in the beginning. So no
simulation data uh required here.
And uh and imagine we have this finite
element model of the beam. It's clamped
on both sides and I'm I'm starting to
push on it from from one side in a in a
horizontal way. H then we know that
after if the if the force is is big
enough then this beam will buckle. So
this this straight configuration where
there's no deformation or no deflection
it becomes unstable and then the beam
snaps either uh up or it it snaps down
um and then these two new fixed points
which are now stable they are born in a
in a bifurcation.
So um much like much like with with
colog of flow uh I thought a good
question to ask would be okay well this
is a a very simple state the the
undelected state what if I construct
this low SSM that is attached to the
simple state can that give me
information about the new states that
are born about these buckle states
and unfortunately the answer is no at
least if if you go by the the Taylor
series uh assumption or Taylor series
method if If you construct this SSM as a
terror series approximation, you can see
this locally near debuckle state, it's
doing a very good job, but just before
it could reach the the the two new
steady states, it just sort of falls off
a cliff and and it's it stops converging
and and diverges. So this would would
not be a very good model again uh for
this dynamical system.
Um at least locally it's good but but
not not globally. Um and we came, long
story short, we came up with a way to
get around this limitation. So we
realized that if only we could convert
this Taylor series expansion that we've
invested a lot of time into um to to
some other representation that may have
different and and better convergence
properties. In particular, if we convert
it to rational functions or a rational
function approximation or or a p
approximate
then um it is known that that they have
a have a the potential to to converge on
much larger domains than the tailaylor
series. And a very important point is
that um so so here's the rational
function uh expression. This is just a
ratio of two polomials. And I I I want
to emphasize that I don't need to do any
new um new computations here. So once
the tailaylor series coefficients are
are determined I can then translate them
directly to the rational function
coefficients. So new no new computation
required
but still look they they converge in a
much larger domain. So they have this
this nice big surface that that we can
trace out uh which now supports the two
new fixed points. These are settle uh
spiral type stable fixed points
corresponding to the buckle states. So
you could say that we have we've
globalized this SSM. we've enlarged this
SSM and and that's why we call it GSSM
and and that is that is very lucky. So
now we have a um we have some dynamical
information on on how this buckling
takes place for example but I I would
say that the reason this is this is even
more important is that now I have a
model of the system that I can trust. So
I can I can try pushing it to its
limits. Um maybe playing with it a
little bit and and see if if that
reproduces some um some actual
phenomena. So I I can try to learn new
things. Right?
For example, I could ask what happens if
I add periodic forcing. So I have this
buckle fixed point and I start pushing
on the middle on the middle node with a
periodic force um just in a in a
vertical direction. It would be
reasonable to ask what is the response
of the system to this this harmonic
pertubation.
And the good news is that because we
have invested a lot of time in in
figuring out the the the analytic
properties of these SSMs, we know that
this is smooth in perturbations. So just
because I'm I'm perturbing it with a um
or or I'm I'm modifying the system to
have a periodic forcing the SSM is not
going to uh disappear.
But I just uh I can just write down a
systematic way of accounting for this
this periodic perturbation. And it turns
out that the to leading order this just
the most important contribution is
actually just comes from the reduced
dynamics. So I don't need to modify the
the parameterization to leading order
but I can add the the forcing in a
projected fashion. So I project the
forcing to the tangent space of this SSM
just add it to the the autonomous vector
field and that gives me a forced
two-dimensional system here and then I
can I can explore that I can I can ask
what what is happening uh in the in the
real system
and surprisingly or or maybe not
surprisingly depending on on how much
you've worked with these kinds of
systems uh this will actually gives rise
to chaotic response very often depending
on the amplitude and the frequency of
the pertubation. But it can respond
chaotically and uh this is what what you
see in the in the full face space. So
then this this chaotic response this is
a a full-blown homocinic clinicinic
tangle that is is born on this attractor
or this this um the attractor is born on
the on the invariant manifold and then I
can use the two dimensional dynamics to
um to simulate what is happening in the
in the real space. You can see a video
comparison of this.
So I was
I guess we lost the lens.
That's where for a while.
Yeah.
Hope he knows.
Uh, hello. I I disconnected or
>> Yes. Uh,
>> I'm sorry.
>> No worries.
>> I think I was on the last slide anyway.
So,
>> okay. Um or did you hear it up to the
last slide or
>> uh I think you were talking on the slide
on the chaotic buckle beam. Um
maybe we just lost you for
for around one and a half and two
minutes.
I think we lost him again.
Um I'm I'm sorry.
>> No.
>> So you were saying uh I I stopped where?
>> Uh on the slide about the chaotic buckle
beam.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Um
may maybe just
uh if you allow me to
to just wrap up very quickly.
>> Yeah. Um
yeah so was it here already?
>> Yes.
>> Okay good. Okay then then I was at the
end. So I was just saying that um we
could predict the chaotic response of
this beam h and that is facilitated by
by this analytic knowledge we have of
these of these manifold. We know that
they are are smooth in the parameters of
the system.
Um and uh in in one sentence just to
just to recap um I I hope to have
convinced you that these SSMs um they
they provide a strong foundation for for
invariant manifold based model reduction
because um what they allow you to do is
to anchor these these invariant
manifolds to something other than just
just viewing them as as as flying
carpets in the face. And because of the
very strong uh mathematical results, we
know that um they allow us to to learn
new things about the systems and
extrapolate to new dynamical regimes. So
very sorry for the for the disconnect
and uh and thank you very much for your
attention.
>> Okay. Yeah. Uh thanks for that wonderful
talk, Lind. Um
so now we have the Q&A section.
Uh if the audience have a question,
please uh feel free to unmute yourself
or post your question to the the chat
room.
So while we wait for the audience to get
their force, I can I'll jump in to ask
some simple questions to kick things up.
>> So please bear with me if if it seems uh
straightforward. So uh I think my my
very first question is how um so I I
think your example on the fluid
structure interaction on the pipe and
the pipe flow
>> problem you both of that uh those you
use a two-dimensional
latent
>> uh I mean coordinate system for the for
the SSM is that right
>> right yeah
>> so so may I ask how I mean is there a
reason rationale how uh you choose like
a two dimensional SSM or I mean Yeah.
How how do you determine the dimension
there?
>> Yeah, it's it's a very good question and
and that's uh so usually locating this
this exact coherent state that we anchor
to and determine the dimension that's
the the main main issues or main
difficulty I should say. So so here for
the for example with the with the pipe
flow
um here I I know roughly the um the the
spectrum of this edge state. So I can I
can count or I can look at the the the
leading values the slowest values. What
I see is that there is one real value
that is positive. So that's would be
unstable and this the the next lowest
one is is real but stable. So real and
negative. So that means if I I want to
um construct something that is larger
than the unstable manifold but still the
the slowest manifold then I need to pick
a two-dimensional um spectral subspace
that spans this. And very similarly with
uh with this one um here we just here we
didn't know the the linear part of the
of the operator because we don't know
the operator but uh but just by by um um
time series analysis you can find out
that it also has a a real and and or two
real values one on each side of the of
zero. So therefore that is that is what
you pick.
See?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Um, yeah, Philillip asked a
question. U, so let me just uh read this
out. So he asked, uh, does this method
help us understand or model the
atmosphere?
>> Um, yeah. So that's that's a that's a
good good question. I I'm wondering the
same thing. So I I I hope to I hope to
work on this a little bit later. Um
what I will say is that
uh that I I put uh Ed Ed Loren here as a
reference and the reason is he he
started talking about these slow
manifolds these atmospheric slow
manifolds very early on and and in in
some sense he his idea was more in terms
of frequencies. So um so enslaving or or
finding relationship between low
frequency and high frequency motions and
that turned out to be not a not a very
useful concept. But if you if you turn
this this around and look at the
relationship between DK rates such as
SSMs,
such as you do with such like you do
with SSMs, then this could potentially a
way be could potentially be a way to to
go towards these low atmospheric
manifolds as well. I hope. Yeah.
>> Okay. Um maybe I can ask one more
question. So uh actually that's related
to on your last slide you you talk about
the generalizability. So I'm thinking
about like okay your method can after
you create this model you can use it to
predict the uh the behavior in the same
system but how about if say there is a
shift in the parameters like if you have
a different ray noise number so I can uh
can you explain to us what are the
difficulties or faults that you may uh
want to do um to generalize your models
because I know like like the easiest and
the jacobian could
Um yeah that that's that's also a good
point. Um in in general as long as as
you know that um the dimension of the
slowest um manifold the slowest spectral
sub manifold doesn't change then this
will also be smoothed in parameters such
as the reel's number. So um I I don't
know if I have a
yeah here I I have a a slide. So in
bipflow we have done this in a rails
number dependent way. It's it's not very
interesting because no no bifurcations
happen in this range. Um but but if if
this assumption is true that that your
your um leading or or slowest spectral
submanifold is always two dimensional
then you can you can just do this in a
rails number dependent way. See
>> um but uh but but yeah you with
bifurcations you you kind of have to be
careful because then some of these
assumptions that go into the um well at
bifurcations you know that these these
turn into center manifolds so that's a a
different type of manifold and uh and
we're we're currently thinking of of how
to stitch that all together. It's not
not very simple but I think it's it is
doable.
See um there's a new question from
Rashelle uh asking um in terms of
computational efficiency so going to uh
to a nonlinear SSM means we may suffer
from the increased computations compared
to a linear model what could be the roll
out um more efficiently can you speak of
this please
>> um yeah it's uh so in a datadriven
setting I think
these types of equations are are
relevant to show here. Um so the the
good thing is that that we don't need to
to go to very high dimensions. So
evaluating these polomials this is a a
polomial of of maybe two or three
variables.
Um evaluating or or fitting it is is
basically instantaneous. It's not not
very computationally heavy. Um and and
same with the reduced dynamics. Now, if
you if you needed a really high
dimensional SSM, like for some reason
you had maybe internal resonances and
you needed to fit a 10 or 20 dimensional
SSM, then I I I wouldn't know what to do
um immediately. So, for example,
probably you need to do you you need to
turn to different function approximation
methods that are are more more efficient
would be my guess.